vous pardonnez Dieu de pas arrêter tout
ce bordel sur la terre
ça va
merci 79 ans
faut parler plus fort
vous avez 79 ans non 79 ans et des
poussières et des poussières
alors vous conservez malgré tout une
activité débordante faut dire les choses
tout à fait honnêtement en ce qui me
concerne en tous les cas au moment de la
disparition de Christine gouzrinal
j'étais un peu inquiet pour vous parce
qu'on s'était parlé un peu au téléphone
je l'avais trouvé un peu abattu et puis
vous avez surmonté l'épreuve
et vous dites finalement qu'à partir du
moment où dans ces cas-là on se suicide
pas faut vivre quoi
oui c'est une la palissade mais c'est
vrai on dit toujours le deuil le deuil
le deuil on le fait mais quand le deuil
est terminé il faut vivre bon aussi moi
j'ai décidé de vivre donc c'est clair je
vais continuer donc à vivre comme ça à
travailler beaucoup ça vous coûte de
vivre pas du tout ça me coûte parce que
je dépense beaucoup d'argent je vois
beaucoup de gens je voyage
[Applaudissements]
en premier cas vous avez bien la forme
alors je disais donc activité débordante
pour Roger Hanin vous avez signé pour
quatre nouveaux navarros ce qui fera 108
quand même c'est pas mal sur France 2
vous allez faire César les vies un
avocat donc voilà donc TF1 France 2 au
cinéma vous avez un film en préparation
qui est très sympa qui s'appelle welcome
Morris c'est une espèce d'Antibes
d'antiggs pardon c'est un vieux caïd qui
sort de prison enfin on voit bien ça va
être intéressant et au théâtre en 2006
vous allez nous donner en attendant
Godot de B4 comme une pièce extrêmement
importante et aujourd'hui vous publiez
votre neuvième livre qui s'appelle
l'horizon chez gras c'est pas mal
alors le pitch est une histoire d'amour
entre un avocat qui a 79 ans et des
poussières
pas loin de vous et une jeune prostituée
maghrébine qui a 15 ans et demi et
quelques siècles voilà mais se mêle à
leur vie le fantôme d'elle
voilà on comprend que c'est la femme
avec laquelle il était marié qui qui
vient de qui vient de disparaître voilà
je pense que peut-être que l'originalité
faut être prudente quand on parle
d'originalité dans un roman c'est que
lui ne veut pas coucher avec un célèbre
couché avec lui mais elle est tellement
aimée vers lui et merveilleux par
quelqu'un qui lui redonne un peu dignité
de d'amour etc que elle veut rester avec
lui une fois dans le livre il couche
avec elle parce qu'il ne veut pas lui
faire de peine toute façon ça vous
dérange pas vous vous avez habité en
Algérie dans la basse case bar vous vous
connaissez ça par coeur les prostituées
et en fait tu sais pourquoi Roger Hanin
n'a pas été Mac c'est parce qu'il s'est
rendu compte que les macs étaient des
indiques c'est vrai
max c'est génial comme boulot mais il
s'est dit s'il faut balancer au KF ça me
plaît pas donc vous l'avez pas j'ai
appris ça sur le top mais quand on est
jeune on est émerveillés par les
chaussures surtout c'est magnifique
comme si elles seront tout a été
dépucelée par Paula la maltaise oui
un jour dans une émission de télévision
60 ans
c'est pas rien quand même ah ben
attendez mondialement
alors celle-ci en tous les cas s'appelle
Myriam donc c'est le cas 15 ans et
quelques siècles elle tapis boulevard
des maraisses chauds mais c'est à l'Alma
que le vieil avocat veuve la rencontre
et alors tout de suite ils partent à
Deauville en Bentley c'est-à-dire on
fait pas dans la dentelle chez vous mais
évidemment je lui dis il faut qu'il
dépense son argent d'ailleurs on met
beaucoup dans la vie dépenser et
pourquoi quand on n'a pas comment
dirais-je de descendance importante
quand on n'a pas investir dans des
affaires pourquoi ne pas dépenser son
argent si on me donne une seule raison
je serai
nombreux c'est ce que je fais
vous dites au sujet de l'argent
finalement je veux mourir nu comme un
verre comme j'étais au sortir du ventre
de ma mère
oui c'est extraordinaire c'est une
lapalissa dans le sort du ventre de sa
mère on a rien vu jamais vu un mec
sortir avec un chapeau des parasites
donc il faut mourir tel qu'on est sorti
du vendredi comme ça c'est bien vrai
donc tout claquer alors on y va
moi j'ai déjà fait un film ouais
c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai beaucoup pensé à vous parce que
c'est un mec un acte courageux d'amour
c'est magnifique c'est bien c'est très
bien en tous les cas donc ce Joseph donc
c'est avocat à honte de son corps c'est
c'est un peu mon cas
on se rend pas compte
alors je vais dire un truc
de mon corps
parce que votre père était c'est du
nudisme oui moi aussi j'étais nudiste et
communiste donc si tu veux se [ __ ] à
poil c'est pas un problème pour lui
non mais c'est vrai que je dis toujours
que la la pudeur s'arrête à la laideur
quoi quand on est pas beau on a pas
envie c'est pas monstrueux je veux dire
mais c'est comme des belles femmes quand
on était très belle emplacement très bon
moi j'étais très beau j'étais un sportif
de haut niveau et puis le corps se
déforme se fatigue on n'a pas envie
j'aimerais être comme vous à votre âge
Roger franchement c'est pas mal hein
j'espère
j'ai fait moins de basket que vous moi
donc effectivement ce qui est très ce
qui est très touchant je trouve dans
votre bouquin c'est qu'il est avec cette
fille qui est très jeune il prend du
plaisir avec elle même s'ils font
l'amour qu'une fois comme vous l'avez
dit mais malgré tout sa femme elle comme
vous l'écrivez c'est à dire elle en
majuscule revient inlassablement dans
l'histoire qu'elle soit là ou pas là
elle est toujours là oui c'est vrai
c'est ce qui m'occupe d'ailleurs dans la
vie mais voilà c'est tout j'ai pas
violoncer le musée là-dessus mais c'est
ça oui
mais ça n'empêche pas de regarder autour
de soi d'être aimé ce que je voudrais
que les gens comprennent c'est qu'on
peut très bien à partir de certains
moments de sa vie ou un certain âge
aimait quelqu'un de très jeune sans
avoir de de de de pulsions érotiques ou
violente ou de possessivité sauf que là
il couche quand même une fois
c'est pour lui faire plaisir pour Pascal
elle se disent
elle elle est plus qu'un souvenir c'est
une présence oui ça n'a rien d'original
c'est une présence moi je dis comment
est-ce qu'ils ont
heureux c'est à dire je suis
complètement dédoublé je viens je crois
force de l'Esprit pour reprendre un mois
de haie d'un homme que vous ne vous
aimez beaucoup c'est ce que j'allais
vous demander est-ce que comme François
Mitterrand vous croyez aux forces de
l'esprit et donc
je crois en Dieu aussi pour un
communiste c'est un petit peu bizarre et
donc je pense que les gens qui nous ont
quitté qu'on aime ils sont là on nous
regarde on nous écoute en tout cas ça me
convient
je suis d'accord avec ça
alors
un de vos plus grands succès Roger Hanin
c'est le grand pardon on va faire une
interview grand pardon
est-ce que vous pardonnerez aux
critiques qui n'aimeront pas votre
bouquin
vous voulez
j'aime beaucoup votre émission je suis
d'être dans le
juge
pardonner je m'en fiche vraiment il y a
eu cinq ou dix ans donc j'étais pas dans
cette disposition d'esprit aujourd'hui
j'explique un jour à Jacques doré qui
nous a quitté que j'aimais beaucoup il
minaudait pour faire de la télévision
pourquoi on a fait ce métier pour faire
les films qu'on aime et pour le plus
grand public or moi pourquoi je crie
pour dire que j'en reviens s'il est
réussi après lecture et qu'on me le dise
le reste
est-ce que vous pardonnez aux
téléspectateurs qui préfèrent Julie
Lescaut
oui oui oui
est-ce que vous pardonnez à une jeune
comédienne qui refuse de vous embrasser
sur la bouche
je sais d'abord des explications
mais je veux qu'on m'explique est-ce que
vous auriez pardonné à votre femme si
elle vous avait trompé je crois pas
c'est minable
elle avait 11 ans de plus que moi
quelquefois comme ça on déconnant envers
moi-même je me dis si je voyais cette
femme qui avait 11 ans plus que moi
je vous estime vous embrasser sur le
bout je serais stupéfait je me demande
une jeune femme qui vous embrasserait
sur la bouche bon bah très bien bon elle
a glissé elle est passée ailleurs mais
une femme qu'on aime c'est comme si je
voyais ma mère embrasser quelqu'un sur
la bouche il est formidable est-ce que
vous pardonnez à Lionel Jospin pour le
21 avril pas du tout pas du tout j'ai dû
un vrai mépris pour cet homme est-ce que
vous pardonnez à TF1 pour des programmes
comme Bataille et Fontaine
vous posez la question de cette pauvre
fille qui a fait l'émission sévelines
Thomas c'est ça moi j'ai pas pardonné
parce que un échec c'est toujours
blessant vous pardonnez Ben Laden pour
le 11 septembre ou pas du tout ou
pardonner Dieu de pas arrêter tous
bordel sur la terre
où est la caméra
s'il vous plaît Dieu faites un effort
voilà
ça marche pas parce que je crois que tu
regardes la une
ça c'est tout Dieu c'est le bordel
est-ce que vous pardonnez les Bleus pour
la dernière Coupe du monde
oui oui
parce que bon le corps est fragile il
est
imprévisible pardonner les femmes qui
vous ont quitté
certaines je les en remercie et d'autres
j'ai eu beau j'ai voulu je suis un
vainqueur etc
dans mon livre et une phrase de Dickens
ne le secouait pas cet homme et plein de
larmes non moi je suis j'ai souvent été
marron on croit toujours donc et j'ai eu
beaucoup de peine j'ai eu des malheurs
mais même le tenace mais j'ai pardonné
oui
si vous étiez Jésus vous pardonneriez
Judas
d'ailleurs on dit aussi pour des gens
qui sont un petit peu pas pervers mais
compliqué que son Judas n'aurait pas eu
de Jésus donc mais moi j'aurais pas les
gens qui trahissent donc j'aime pas
beaucoup Judas
est-ce que vous pardonnez bouche si vous
étiez Irak moi
je pense oui
est-ce que vous pardonnez aux Juifs de
ne pas vouloir pardonner la chose
j'écris le livre le livre précédent
s'appelle Gustave
fin de soirée de nuit de Beuvry
un juif dit il faut que les Juifs
pardonnent la Shoah
comme ça il deviendrait un peuple
au-dessus de tout soupçon
et
l'arabe qui est avec qui s'appelle
Lakhdar
et hier tu l'aurais dit non mais
aujourd'hui je le dis je suis content
pour l'avoir dit alors il faudrait que
si l'Argentine ou l'Italie pardonnait la
joie ça serait
d'un double choix mais que le peuple
juif dise nous pardonnons la joie
pas les tortionnaires je veux dire le
phénomène de la Shoah je trouve que ce
serait extraordinaire alors qu'est-ce
que j'ai entendu et qu'est-ce que je
vais entendre mais pas que chez vous on
peut tout dire alors
est-ce que vous pardonnez aux gens qui
n'ont pas cru en vous
je vais être un tout petit peu je m'en
fous
est-ce que vous pardonnez à François
Mitterrand pour son attitude pendant
l'occupation alors je peux parler si
j'aime bien cette question écoutez ces
monstrueux le procès qu'on lui fait je
veux dire je le connais bien et je suis
avant de venir ici vous me fait rire
d'une synagogue et donc mais François
Mitterrand il est prisonnier il sait que
ça se passe à Vichy
il voit comment ça se passe ça lui
convient pas il entre dans la Résistance
personne ne nous conteste ce chemin là
et dans la Résistance personne ne
grossesse à la distance
qu'est-ce qu'on peut lui reprocher
d'être venu à Vichy d'avoir pris la
francise
des femmes de la mort des Juifs voilà
bon et je peux vous dire que c'était un
homme un jour à table je disais bon moi
qui suis donc communiste et donc
universaliste disant un jour les Juifs
disparaîtront ils vont se fondre et ils
épousent la plupart et plus des des
Françaises des catholiques moi j'ai bon
et un jour était il me dit mais ce
serait dommage il disparaisse mais
pourquoi ce serait des hommes et des
femmes on va arrêter mais non parce que
il perdait de leur culture
leur histoire leur humour il faut que
les Juifs perturbent
je veux bien le croire mais comment
expliquer vous non mais je crois mais
comment expliquer vous qu'il ait fallu
attendre 1995 Jacques Chirac qui le
premier a reconnu la culpabilité de la
France dans le comportement envers les
Juifs pendant la guerre comment se
fait-il que Mitterrand contre lui poser
la question n'est jamais voulu
reconnaître la culpabilité de la France
je le sais vous allez comprendre j'avais
le sens de l'État et de l'histoire il a
eu raison moi j'aime beaucoup Jacques
Chirac il a eu raison François
Mitterrand de pas reconnaître le la
responsabilité de la France il a dit
c'est l'état français c'est pas la
France tous les Français ne sont pas
responsables de ça et ceux qui ne sont
pas responsables de ça comment ils le
ressentent ils sont français ils aiment
la France non non moi je trouve que la
position de François Mitterrand est
bonne vous êtes tenace c'est bien et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu